Is this a data rich or
data poor problem?
Let's recall the difference
between data rich and data poor.
If we have past data on the variable
we're trying to predict,
then we're data rich.
Otherwise, we're data poor.
To determine whether we're data rich or
poor we need to look at our data
to get a better understanding.
Looking at our data set,
we see that we have the following
information on each client.
The average number of tickets
each client submits per week,
the number of employees per client, the
value of the contract with each client,
and the industry of each client.
Since we have the number of tickets for
each client, or data rich.
Moving down the flow chart,
next we need to determine if we should
use a numeric model, or
classification model.
Our target outcome that we're trying
to predict is the number indicating
the average number of tickets
we can expect per client.
Therefore we should use a numeric model.
Now we're getting closer to
determining which model to use.
But first we need to
determine if a continuous or
time based model is appropriate for
our problem.
We're looking for an average per week.
So at first glance we might think
this is a time based problem.
If we were looking to forecast
a specific number per calendar week for
a period of weeks, we'd be correct.
However, in this problem,
we just want an average per week and
are not interested in
the specific calendar week.
Therefore, we'll use a continuous
model to solve our problem.
For our first model,
let's focus on linear regression.
We'll cover the others later.